well Kim this is super exciting thank
you for joining me on et Canada progress
thank you for having me I'm excited I'm
excited I'm a huge fan thank you first
and foremost Congrats on all your
success amazing as a fan from the start
to just see what you are building with
your career and it is at a point where
it is just you're selling out shows
you're creating some of the best pop
music out there how are you feeling
about things in your career right now
thank you yeah I feel amazing
I it's been like the last time I was in
Toronto was a year ago opening for Troy
I had a little banner that set my name
behind me now I have a full show and
it's sold out and it's but I have a ton
of songs out my first project came out I
just I haven't stopped working so I feel
tired just from working a lot all the
time but I feel amazing like I'm truly
like living my dream now and it's been
like so many years that I've put put
into this and for that it's kind of
happened pretty fast
but I feel like you have just been on a
tour bus for a month now so I'm a little
like loopy to be honest people this cuz
you mentioned that you're tired but a
big question I always ask people is have
you had time to actually because you're
going from one city to the next yeah
you're constantly go go go go go have
you had time to sit down and reflect on
everything that you have achieved so far
and everything that you are doing no I
don't think so that's the thing like I'm
going to over Christmas so I'm really
excited for that but it's just I've been
working so hard to get to this point
where I have work every single day and
you know I've been like writing so many
songs and sending them to everybody for
years and years movers before I got to
do this myself but now I just feel like
it's go time and like every second that
I like sit down I just feel like I owe
it to myself and to my fans now to write
the next song and make the next video
and come up with the next outfit and the
next tour but yeah although Christmas I
like sit down and like you know realize
to take it all in Kylie Jenner likes to
say this is the Europe realizing stuff
it is the year of legalizing stop I
realized what a great songwriter you are
I mean turn off the light
fantastic thank you so much clarity
though I have to say that album really
speaks to me I love it just from those
opening lyrics writing that album what
did you set out to achieve because a
debut studio album is your calling card
to the world so what did you want your
message to be well my songs that I
dropped before that that kind of got me
to the place where I could drop my first
record were kind of me talking about
what I wish my life was like and they
were also about heartbreak and like they
were kind of the beginning phases of
this but this was just more refined
actual me it was just like me finding
confidence kind of to be myself and to
talk about myself and my own internal
feelings and just to like let my like
personality like fully come through so
it just felt like kind of a like a
little bit like a reveal
[Music]
it was cool because I just really set
out to make a record that got people
over breakups because I went through a
really bad one and just I feel like all
these songs are really touching on that
but really uplifting at the same time
which I always want to do like I always
want to have like that little bit that's
like but may have hurt me but like I'm
only better and prettier I always wanted
to feel like it's just like it's like
it's like it's uplifting at the same
time as being like man I wish I didn't
like suck it love you know is there any
fear though when you are because this is
something that will be around forever
like an album will always be out there
is their fear of putting too much of
yourself into a song when you're writing
ever do you ever worry that you're
giving too much of yourself no I feel
like if I did then the songs would
become not good I always feel like it's
like the listener isn't stupid and I
feel like if I try to cover something up
I feel like they will know immediately
yeah and so no I feel like a huge reason
of why I write songs because I feel like
in life sometimes I can't properly
express myself and like things I say to
people are so quick and I wish I could
write along you know a song out of how I
actually want to sing it and that's like
a huge reason for me why I started
writing songs it's just because I
thought misunderstood and because I
wanted people to understand me and was
just like desperately looking for you
know people to get me and get what I'm
saying and now I feel like my fans do
and so that's like an amazing feeling
and that's what fans are connecting with
I think with you is that you are an open
book you're willing to go there and talk
about things that some people may not be
yeah totally and that's what what I'm
looking for in artists you know that's
the artist that I listen to it's just
the ones that I can relate to and that I
can definitely say like you're talking
about something that's real to you and
then something to you
[Music]
what I find now I've been working in
entertainment for a long time I find the
industry has changed quite a bit there
are artists like yourself artists like
carly rae jepsen artists like Charli XCX
who are out on the road and absolutely
killing it every night selling out shows
you may not have a Hot 100 number one
yet yeah one day and it's not you know
what maybe that's okay
yeah are you realizing now that things
like there's a huge debate about you
know Halsey was upset about the Grammys
and not being nominated I mean I think
in Petra should have been I mean we can
all get upset about things that maybe we
don't get but how are you feeling about
your career right now because like I
said you have your own label yeah which
is incredible you're selling out shows
you're sold out tonight in Toronto and
you have a die-hard fan base I feel so
like successful right now I really do
like I'm doing this by myself with my
own label I started from nothing and
performing in like clubs with like five
people and then we didn't know anything
about me I was writing so Matt hunts and
hundreds of songs before ever got to the
point where anybody would listen to my
songs and I'd have like ten fans on
soundcloud for years you know so for me
just building this all myself with my
vision with how I want to look with how
I want to talk about things with being
exactly who I am
with being transgender with all of those
things that are different you know I'm
just building my own platform because
labels and label heads taught me I would
always be neat and I would you know as a
transgender honest I couldn't do all of
these things so I'm really just like
making my own path and on my own tempo
yeah and I am NOT like in a rush I feel
like every time I do something I get
better yeah and I keep learning and I
keep releasing things that are different
and new and I feel like every time I
drop a record
like whoa this is such a fast like
development of like and I feel I feel
that way like I feel really proud of
just like learning and all of that stuff
so I feel really successful of course if
you compare people all the time like I'm
not on the radio all the time
I don't have a number one song but I
feel so successful and I don't think
this would have been possible at all
that even like ten years ago
yeah I agree I'm still proving to people
like I can be more than like a nice like
job just kind of transgender like
gimmick people feel they need to label
everything yeah I see Kim as Kim the
artist you know I don't see Kim as the
trans artist but it is important to
continue to speak about things it's just
your fan base you have a huge queer fan
base yeah how does it feel to be a role
model I feel like I was like born and
raised in gay clubs like that's like
what I set out to do originally like I
wanted to make songs for me and my
friends with who are always engaged
listening to like Kylie Minogue you know
so I always wanted to make that that
kind of music that kind of record and
that also like it's just like you listen
to the radio it's not right now it's not
like club song yeah it's not like super
kind of flamboyant pop which is what I
feel like I do and I want to make in
which I love which is the reason I make
music
[Music]
I feel honored to be in this position
and at the same time sometimes I feel
like a little bit of a guinea pig
because I'm the first one kind of
figuring it out and kind of yeah I run
into things where I'm like you know I
talked about being transgendered too
much and then people are like you're
using your identity and then I don't
talk about it and people don't want to
be a face for transgender people and in
actual actuality I'm proud of being
transgender and I want to help and I
think visibility is the most important
thing right now and just people being
aware of the word transgender and that
it exists and that's something normal
and it's not freaky that you can have
normal life and be transgender and then
at the same time I just wish that labels
could disappear I love what happened in
Kansas box with the Westboro Baptist
Church strong boards those were
incredible and when you see something
like that I don't know if you had a hand
in that if you did amazing Congrats if
you didn't and your fans whatever um but
I feel like as members of the queer
community we need to sometimes have
things up a bit and stir the pot for
sure and no I I completely loved it like
I I just think stuff like that is so it
was so funny to me when I found out it
was just like no funniest thing ever and
yeah I just I really have no problem of
like outraging people especially
ignorant people and just kind of shoving
it in their face that I exist from that
that's okay what message does Kim send
two members of the lgbtq+ community who
are maybe feeling unsure of who they are
or what they can achieve or what they
can do in this life what would you say
to them I think you can do anything you
set your mind to I really do believe in
that I think no dream or goal is big
enough and yeah I feel like you can do
it in the world is changing in your
favor and things are getting better and
again ten years ago none of this would
have been possible imagine 10 years from
now what you can do so I think there's
so much hope I think it's never too late
for anything I think
you can always just manifest your moment
[Music]